[Music]
yeah hello
it's great to be here my name is klaus
wilkie i'm with the university of texas
at austin
and today i'm talking about work that
has been sponsored by the r consortium
that's why they're prominently featured
in the bottom and it's about
improving text rendering in ggplot so a
common problem
that probably all of you at some point
have run into
is you may want to mix italics and
normal text in ggplot
so my in my day work i'm a biologist so
it's a very common problem for
biologists you have species names that
are supposed to be in italics but then
you have other texts surrounding it that
shouldn't be in italics
so how can we make that happen and so
just to
to give you an an example of how that
may
arise here's a stuck overflow issue that
asking that question
for my plot figure i want to label
categories on a bar plot with the first
word being italicized while the
following words are not
italicized i want the category labels to
look as follows and so there's a typical
biology example there's a bacterial name
i'm not trying to pronounce it
and then otu1 operational taxonomic unit
that's
a biology term but in any case so this
should be italics
this should not be italics right
so let's look a little more into the
example code and data that comes with
this
issue so this made up data set
that the person provided we have in the
first column then the name of the
bacterial species
then we have these otus then we have a
name column that combines the bacterial
species and the otus
and then we have some numeric value and
so the person was turning this
into a bar plot with just three lines of
ggplot right you take the data
pipe it into ggplot put name on
x and value on y but then we flip the
coordinates so we get a horizontal plot
and of course you see the problem in
this plot is that the bacteria names are
not in italics
so how can we solve the problem now the
common solution that you will find for
that
is some sort of plot math so this is the
accepted solution
in on stack overflow you can make a
vector of expressions and apply to the
labels argument in scale x discrete
and so the the code that makes the magic
happen is this code here
quote italic parenthesis single quote
double quote
comma x bracket one
i i cannot write that code i'm sure
there's people in this room who can
write that code and i salute you
i cannot and i don't want to um
i would rather write my own text
rendering software in c
plus plus
and so that's what i've done
okay so uh but that
leads us to the question so how should
we specify
formatted text so let's make first a
slightly simple example
instead of the the axis tick label says
let's just look at the title
okay i want a title species names are
in italics and italics should be in
italics
and maybe i've already given it away so
i put italics in stars
anybody that has used markdown
knows this right if you're using our
markdown if you want something in it
in italics you put stars around it and
so
that's what this package gd text
facilitates
so as of right now it's still in
development you have to
install it from github but it's
essentially ready to go it's just
waiting for the next release of ggplot
so with some time within the next
two to three months this should be on
crown so i've now loaded the package
nothing has happened yet because i
haven't changed anything
in the code it wouldn't be good if just
randomly
stars were interpreted as markdown
because maybe sometimes you actually
want to have stars in your text
so so we have to tell gdplot that now it
should interpret this as markdown
and so i've hooked this up with the
theme system so that
now if you've ever used themes in ggplot
usually
the plot dot title is that
tells us how the title of the plot is
styled and normally you would write
element text and then you can use that
to change the color and so on
and now i've written this element
markdown and so now you see this has
been interpreted as markdown and so now
this in italics is in italics
okay so now let's apply this
to the original problem so the
additional issue here now
is that we have these different species
names and we don't want to manually put
them into stars
we want to automate that right and so
there
a really really good companion package
is the glue package
if you're not routinely using glue i
encourage you to look into it
glue allows you to very quickly paste
pieces from your data frame into strings
of text
so i'm taking the data here
pipe into mutate and then i i create a
new name column where i call
glue and then here i have this star
and then back name is the column name
that has the bacterial name in
curly braces and that tells glue don't
write back name
into the string but actually pull it
from the data frame and then here the
same with otu name
and so that now creates this table where
now you see i have nice stars
around the bacterial names and so now i
pipe this into ggplot with the element
markdown
so now it's of course the axis.txt.y
that i want to change and now you see
this is in italics this is not
okay i see this solves the problem
okay so now you might say okay your
plots are boring
don't you ever use color i do
i do so let's do something with color um
let's actually let's add a color
column i i i'm doing a little bit of a
trick so if hardly hardly is not in the
room right he would say
you're circumventing this scale system
yes in this case that's the right way to
do it so
i'm adding i'm adding a color vector so
these are just colors
that i've that it shows and now what i'm
i'm still using glue but now you may see
here i'm actually writing a little bit
of
html so this is uh the italics tag now
and i'm using
inline css styling to to get the color
in there
and with that i can actually have now
colors
so the trick that i'm using here is i'm
using scale fill identity
so i'm mapping color onto fill and then
scale fill identity
instead of trying to set up a color
mapping it just takes
the actual colors that are in the column
now one other thing that you may notice
it's it's
a topic that's very dear to my heart you
may notice that visually these colors
and these colors look kind of the same
right
they match very well but i'm actually
setting the transparency to 0.5
here so the bars are actually
at 50 percent transparency and then they
look the same as the text
which is completely opaque and that's
just how our visual system works when
you color large areas
you need the color to be lighter it's a
very common problem that i see when
people color text
that the text becomes too light like the
text
always needs to use a darker color to
to look the same as a large area that
you colored the same
so this worked out well so if you make
the color 50
transparent it's going to be about right
okay so now we're getting
uh ambitious right
what what else can i do um so this is
another
issue from stack overflow it's another
biological problem so it's it's
made up data the the key thing here is
there are these phases so these are
phases of cell division
again a biological example and so this
person had these different images
and so this image corresponds to this
phase this image corresponds to this
phase and so on
and so the question was can we somehow
get the images
into the figure and we can
so now we're using the image tag we're
we're loading
or we're setting the images so this
in this particular case is in a folder
on my hard drive but you can pull them
from a web page if you want that works
just fine we put a break
tag and then the word and we stick it
into ggplot the only other thing is
line height the default line height for
some reason is just too low
it's 0.9 i don't know why 1.2 is a
better line height if you actually want
to have things in two lines
and there we go we have the images in
the axis
and the label underneath
i i see this solves another problem very
good
there's there's a few other things that
that it can do
um so there's actually the option to
have text boxes
with some amount of text wrapping uh and
you can color the background um
if if you go to to the website which is
in the bottom right corner
you can see the code that makes this
particular
figure okay so everything i've shown so
far is theme elements right does this
only work for theme elements no i also
have written
a geom that you can use to to use the
same text rendering
in a plot so let's do another common
situation
so this is the iris data set which i
assume everybody knows so we have three
species
of iris flowers we're plotting the sepal
width
against the sepal length for the three
species and we're putting regression
lines in here
right and so oftentimes when you have a
plot like that
you may want to annotate this with say
the r squared of the regression line
right and so it's again the problem okay
how do i get the r square
into some plot math expression that then
i can add to the plot
um and so we'll
instead of doing that use the same
technique here so let's let's just go
through the code quickly so first we
calculate the correlation
right so we take the iris data set group
by species summarize calculate the r
square
so then we end up with the table that
has the species names
and the r square right and now
we turn this into our labels so this
sample length and several width 8 and
4.5 those are just the coordinates where
the label will
appear in the plot and then again i use
the glue function
so i have r in star so it's going to be
italics
superscript 2 because it's going to be r
squared and here i'm
pasting in the correlation coefficient
and i round it to two digits so
in the glue package inside the square
brackets you can just write j
regular r code and it gets executed and
replaced by the resulting
string and then this goes into gg plot
into a geom rich text
which takes the label and interprets it
as
html and so now you have here this label
r squared equals whatever so by default
it it puts a white background and a box
around it but all of that you can change
you can take the box away
if you want you can put a different
background and so on
so that's really all i can do
however there's actually there's
actually two packages that i've written
so this package
was the gd text package which provides
the interface
to ggplot but it's really just a wrapper
around an underlying package so the
package that makes it all possible
and that already is on cran and that's
the grid text package
and so that is a great package if you're
actually
writing grid graphics code so for
example if you're writing your own
ggplot extensions
and i've made it so that if you're used
to writing grid code it should be very
easy to use the grid text package so
if you've never seen grid code this may
look scary but if you have seen grid
code this should be very familiar so
this is
so far just regular grid
i i have some text here then i set up
grid graphics parameters so gpa graphics
parameters i'm using a silly font
with some font size and a color and then
i create a
text graph drop sense for graphics
object
text the coordinates x and y horizontal
justification in the graphics parameters
and then i call the grid.graph draw
function to draw it
and i get this outcome okay and so
now in addition i draw the same string
but using the the rich text drawing
function from grid text
and so it looks like this so now i have
rich text drop
text coordinates h just gp so it looks
exactly the same
i put a different coordinate here so
they're in different
y locations right this is why it's point
this at point seven is point four but
you can actually plot them on top of
each other and they they should
pretty much look exactly the same and
then you just draw it
okay and that's
it actually uh i i wanna end with one
word of caution so you may now think oh
great i can do anything
that is not true you can pretty much do
exactly what i
showed you and not more
so so the issue is that
i'm not handing off the html
to a web browser that that renders it or
some professional text rendering library
for technical reasons there's just no
good way right now to achieve that so
i had to write my own rendering engine
from scratch
and so my approach was okay what are
like the
five things that i can implement in a
reasonable amount of time
that really really make a difference and
like the number one
is italics and bold the number two is
colors
number three is being able to change
fonts so you can change a different font
if you want to
number four is superscripts and
subscripts and then number five is
images
um so that's where i currently am
you can do a lot with that but like just
this morning
i i got this this bug report that i was
just waiting for which listed 100
markdown features that don't currently
work
yes i know they don't currently work
the truth is my vision is to
increase the number of features that we
support
at this point we have a good user
interface that i think will remain
stable and so i can now keep adding
features and just like eventually at
some point
certain things may work that right now
don't work but
anything that works now should continue
to work and the r code so
the r code should not change going
forward
so with that make
plots with formatted text
do you want to take some questions yeah
all right great we have a couple minutes
for questions here
so let me go down the list all right
there were a lot of questions in here
that you just covered at the end like
what else
what else is available so i will scroll
through those but do you have any
thoughts on
adding shorthand markdownish syntactic
sugar around the html tags for this work
um i i'm not sure i understand the
question so
so the way that this whole thing works
is it actually
it takes the mark down it it sends it
through the regular markdown package
that is part of r
which turns it into html and then the
html gets rendered so
anything that you're used to doing in in
markdown
works in theory as long as the resulting
html is actually supported
right so going forward what i need to do
is i need to support more html
features and actually the biggest issue
right now is i need to support more css
because that that's the next big
stumbling block for a lot of obvious
features that you would want to have
and then the markdown should just come
by itself
through the existing maca markdown
package awesome thanks
all right i was really happy to see some
glue in there because i
love that package but we have some folks
in the audience who wanted to know
what is the advantage of using glue over
paste or paste zero
so so the advantage of glue over paces
is just that it may be slightly easier
to write in particular if you have a lot
of
things right so um
where was it somewhere here actually
let's go to the colors
sorry i don't know the way around my own
i mean paste would work just the same
right if you like paste use paste
but i find this very easy to read
these curly braces are very
low overhead right so it's very easy to
just look at that piece of text that
comes out and says yes
this looks correct versus with with
paste
it gets a bit more complicated to figure
out what the final output actually will
be
here's one about uh do you have any tips
for incorporating
um non-standard fonts into plots
that might not be available on your
machine
okay so so this first of all this
package
doesn't solve that this package work
will work with any font
that works regularly in in your r
setup right so the problem of having
other fonts like
thomas is working on that the long-term
goal is that any font that you have
installed on your machine should just
work
and actually on on macs that actually
works
reasonably well honestly like any any
font that the
operating system knows i can use like i
installed actually
font awesome from the web and then i
could put little icons into plots
i didn't demonstrate that today but that
worked just fine so as long as
r supports the font it will work in this
case but
but how to make that happen that's
really for thomas
excellent all right uh and lastly of
course where are your slides available
where can i completely forgot about that
so i actually tweeted it out
right before actually earlier this
morning so if you go at
klaus wilkie that's my twitter handle
and the last tweet i made or the second
to last tweet i made
is the slides all right thank you so
much klaus